قد ينقسم التونسيون بشان قرارات رئيس قيس
سعيد بين مؤيد ومعارض وان اختلفت نسب
لكنهم يجمعون على ان بلدهم يمر بازمه
الاقتصاديه خانقه اخر صرخات التحذير جاءت
من الاتحاد التونسيل الصناعه والتجاره
الذي قال ان اقتصاد البلاد في خطر ودعاء
الى برنامج عاجل لانقاذه واوضح ان
الميزانيه العامه لسنه 2023 ستعلق ازمه
الثقه التي تعيشها تونس الاتحاد العامه
مصر الشغل اعلن من قبل ان قانون الماليه
لا يلبي طموحات مواطن الذي ارهقه ارتفاع
الاسعار وتدهور قدره الشرائيه في مقابل
هذه المواقف يتهم الرئيس التونسي اطرافا
لم يسمها بالوقوف وراء نقص مواد اساسيه في
اسواق الوضع لكنه مشكله نقص هذه المواد
مستمره منذ شهور وهي مده ربما كانت كافيه
للكشف عن من يقف وراء هذا النقص الذي
يسيبه في الارتفاع الكبير للاسعار تتعقد
الازمه اذا ومعها تتعقد الحلول فقد انهى
تونس عام 22 بمعدل تضخم وصل الى اكثر من
10% وهو الاعلى منذ 40 عاما ويتوقع البنك
المركزي التونسي انتصر نسبه الى 23% خلال
السنه الجاريه ما هي الحلول اذا في ظل
لهذا الوضع الميزانيه العامه تعد لايجاد
الحلول وتحقيق التنميه لكن هذا العمال
واتحاد الصناعه والتجاره اجمع على انتقاد
قانوني 2023 لما تضمنه من اجراءات منها
رفع ضريبه القيمه المضافه لبعض مهن الحره
مثل المحامين والاطباء ورفع الدعم امام
انسداد الافقي في الداخل تعول السلطه على
حل ياتي من الخارج ففي بلد تشكل فيه
الماديته 80% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
تتفاوض السلطه مع صندوق النقد الدولي
للحصول على قادمه مليار و900 مليون دولار
يتحدث البعض عن هذا القرد كمخلص لكنه
شروطه صندوق النقد الدولي منها مراجعه
نظام الدعم او الغاؤه تدريجيا ومراجعه
نظام الضرائب والتحكم في كتله الاجور
واعاده هيكله المؤسسات العموميه المتعثره
يمكن ان تؤدي الى احتقان اجتماعيا يعقد
الازمه اكثر لم يتفق حتى الان على القرض
وحتى لو تم الاتفاق عليه يعتقدوا خبراء
واقتصاديون انه مجرد مسكن ولن ياتي
بالعلاج الحقيقي